[موسيقى]
لذا استعرض بعض الميزات
الجديدة للبكسل لهذا اليوم ، ما هي
أكبر الوجبات السريعة هناك الكثير من
التقنيات في البكسل 4 ، فهي تحتوي على
شريحة رادار جديدة نسميها إحساس الحركة
والتي تتيح لك رؤية الإيماءات وأشياء من
هذا
القبيل أيضًا  لديه مساحة على القفل ، لذا فهو
سيفتح الهاتف بسرعة
ويقطع يعملان معًا حتى يتم تشغيله
بشكل أسرع ومن ثم بالطبع
أنظمة الكاميرا الجديدة رائعة ، لذا فهي
للأشخاص الذين يبحثون عن
أحدث المعجبين بـ Google الذين يريدون
أفضل ما تقدمه Google وما
نقدمه ، يبدو أن ظهر الجهاز
مشابهًا إلى حد ما لجهاز iPhone ،
ولكنه يزيد بمقدار 100 دولار عن تكلفة الطراز الأساسي ،
كيف تختار خطة الشركة
التميز في السوق وكيف
يمكنك  تبرير التكلفة جيدًا أولاً ،
نعتقد أنه يقارن بشكل إيجابي مع جهازي
iPhone الأعلى
تكلفة وهما أغلى ثمناً ولدينا أيضًا منتج pixel 3a
وهو رائع للأشخاص الذين
يبحثون عن هاتف ذكي قوي للغاية
e بميزانية محدودة ، فهي تتمتع بجميع
أعمال الكاميرا الرائعة ولديها أيضًا إمكانية الوصول
إلى مساعد Google ، لذا فإن
الجمع بين الاثنين يمنح الأشخاص
خيارًا رائعًا إذا كانوا يحاولون شراء
هاتف ذكي بميزانية محدودة يبحثون عن
هاتف رائع ثم  تظهر أحدث
التقنيات في pixel
for crock الذي يشبه أفضل البرامج
الرئيسية المتاحة لشخص
مهتم حقًا بمصادر نظام Android
البيئي ، ويقول أن البكسل يستحوذ على
ما يقرب من 1 إلى 2 ٪ من
سوق الهواتف الذكية العالمي اليوم أعلنت الشركة
أن  ستأتي
إلى المزيد من شركات النقل ، هل تأمل في أن
يزيد ذلك نوعًا ما أو
يشجع على زيادة النمو والمستخدمين ،
نعم ، أعني أننا نعمل متحمسين جدًا
للإطلاق مع شركاء اتصالات جدد من الواضح أن
هناك أشخاصًا يرغبون حقًا في الشراء
من  الناقل الخاص بهم ، كما تعلم ، نحن بسبب
أعمال الأجهزة ، لذلك نريد أن نبقى
مركزين في المناطق الجغرافية التي ندعمها ،
ونريد التأكد من حصولنا على
تجربة المستخدم بشكل صحيح حقًا قبل
التوسيع
نظرًا لأن Google تريد الاستمرار في صنع الأجهزة من
الواضح أن سجلك موجود في البرامج
والخدمات ، فلماذا تستمر في دفع الأجهزة ،
نعم جيدًا ، أعني أننا شعرنا أن أفضل
طريقة للابتكار لمستخدمينا للأشخاص
الذين أرادوا حقًا أن تكون أحدث
تقنيات Google هي بداية البناء و
والخبرات في الوقت الحالي ، تقع صناعة الحوسبة
في مكان يتباطأ فيه قانون مور
، وبالتالي فهي مكان
يتعين عليك فيه تصميم أنظمة كاملة إذا
كنت تريد أن تكون في طليعة هذا المجال ، لذا
فنحن نطور أنظمة للأشخاص
الذين يريدون  أفضل ما في Google
وأحدث ابتكاراتنا وهذا هو سبب وجودنا
في لعبة المنتجات النهائية الآن
[موسيقى]